for the latest mini election trip i'm
off to essex to speak to the coaches
energy Sajid Javid threw it out
campaigning with hollow MP Rob Halford
he's one of the five phases of the
conservative campaign the campaign which
has failed to put the Tories into first
place so far it's Javid at all worried
about the party's possible causes of the
conservative campaign a lot of it's been
dominated by negativity about Ed
Miliband and labor do you think that
turns off voters at all I actually think
since the campaign's er started it's
been very very positive we just look at
the last week of what we've seen with
the budget and what we've talked about
their about helping hard-working people
helping save as helping pensioners I
mean none of that is negative that's all
about helping people and showing them
what a difference in government can make
but it was still a message around the
budget saying em don't let labour wreck
the economy so there's this built
elements no I think it's important to
always talk about what you're doing and
the difference that makes and give them
huge increase in jobs the massive fall
therefore in unemployment you're the big
tax cuts for some of the lowest paid
people in our society I mean that these
are all positives that's all we should
be talking about but at the same time I
think it's absolutely right to remind
people of the mess the previous
government left behind and that if you
go back to those kinds of policies that
they had of more borrowing more spending
more dead you're like to end up back in
the same place why do you think the
Conservatives aren't ahead in the polls
yet it was reported that you thought you
might be had in genuine and then in
February and in march and winnellie
april and you're still vining first
place with labor i think what we're
going to see is your first of all like
any election there are millions of
people out there the floating voters and
others that don't make up their mind
until probably quite late in the day
maybe in the last couple of weeks I
think many people are just starting to
think of the election now I mean that's
very of you me or people that you know
they're in the word in Westminster MPs
and things they think about this every
day but the person in the street it's
something they'll only focus on as we
get close to election day I think for
many of them when they do they will
focus on the choice and they know yes
lots of parties but there's only two
people that can end up in number ten is
David Cameron is Ed Miliband and the
choices competence vs chael so I think
when they focus on it that way that
you'll see the Conservatives doing much
much better so if it is that choice do
you think the Prime Minister's to do a
head-to-head debate with EDD Miliband
well actually the latest news is the
debates issue has been settled once a
good thing well there is one debate
happening but it's not the original
debate that was proposed by the
broadcaster's and this is a tricky thing
for you because you're the culture
secretary having to keep relations good
with them well the good thing is we have
a independent broadcasting system and
they should decide you know how they
want to do things and how they want to
offer them but at the same time it's
perfectly correct that political leaders
including the obviously David Cameron
but also for any politically they can
then decide what they do want to do what
they don't want to do but the important
thing is they've all come together
they've reached an agreement and
everyone can look forward to it and
finally it the last election a sixteen
percent of ethnic minority voters
supported the Conservative Party and do
you agree with what bonus party said
that the Tories will lose the Muslim
vote at this election no i don't i think
that we're working hard to appeal to all
voters across the country whether effet
minority or not but what all voters want
and i think that's that's the important
part of our message it doesn't matter
whether you're ethnic minority or not it
doesn't matter if you're working class
or not what all voters want to see is an
economy that's growing that's prosperous
that's able to generate the jobs people
want and also a strong economy that can
then help pay for the public services
that we want and what about the comments
by Lord Bates this weekend one of your
home office ministers about immigrants
having too many children I think all
that's about is a recognition that
excessive immigration is a problem and
it needs to be dealt with if not a your
immigration is a good thing for our
country we have benefited from it in so
many ways but everyone recognizes that
when it's excessive then that's the
issue and that's why you need to control
numbers and that is something that
clearly trying to do the results haven't
been you know the overwhelming you know
clear we need to do more work but that's
something that's ongoing work and making
sure that we can have people that come
to our country
but are making a contribution and I
think that's important do you agree with
Lord betas comments then no I don't
think that's what he meant at all i
think he's been misquoted I think we're
all he's referred to another's is the
issue of excessive immigration which I
think everyone pretty much agrees on you
know we immigration great thing for our
country it's good to have people that
come and want to work and want to make a
contribution but we don't want excessive
immigration and it's right for us and
actually I think for any country we want
to know that they're controlling the
number of people that are entering the
country and that's it for this mini
electric venture join me again soon to
fire how the election is being fought in
a different part of the country find out
more mini election Cove WK